è difficilissimo questa operazione non è
facile come percorso non lo è facile per
me perché Imparo ogni giorno una cosa in
più e a rapportarmi con delle difficoltà
che fuori non non le pensiamo Allora
quello che chiedo a tutti Oggi però è
speciale per noi quanto per voi entra un
pubblico esterno che non sa che noi
stiamo tutti i giorni qua allora insieme
tutti detenuti appuntati io ci siamo
presi tutti una responsabilità rispetto
all'esterno Quindi quello che vi chiedo
a tutti tutti tutti Oggi è veramente
provare a pensare quanto ci siamo
Sforzati per arrivare a questo e che
oggi c'è un pubblico esterno che ha
l'opportunità di vedere la parte bella
del
carcere Io ci provo è una un'iniziativa
che non conoscevo prima seguendo questo
percorso capisco anche che sia venuta
fuori un'energia positiva da da dentro
solitamente uno in una stanza di 2 m si
contiene con emozioni cioè vedo più una
persona depressa c'è tanta emotività
dentro e bisogna cacciarla fuori questo
fa Io ci provo un po' lo spirito è
un'esperienza che dà Innanzitutto
modo di socializzare con gli altri ci si
sblocca ci si affronta una situazione
differente in questo
contesto cari miei il fascino
particolare di questo gioco sta nel
sentirsi cogliere dall'inquietudine E
dalla paura Tutto ad un tratto ci si
chiede se fossi davvero un delinquente
secondo quello che penso io L'importante
in carcere attraverso Ori Ricominciare o
cominciare ad avere un obiettivo io ci
provo il gruppo di teatro invece ti
mette sul piatto tutte queste
cose facciamo un cerchio così ci
salutiamo si state un bel gruppo alla
fine C c'era il gruppo Mi raccomando non
vi fate coinvolgere da quello che c'è
dentro il
carcere Perché può cambiare se non si
cambia dentro Non si può cambiare fuori
grazie
Grazie a
lei ma veramente Grazie a te oggi era
bello
bellissimo penso che Paola sia una
persona molto speciale come lei così
anche tutti i suoi collaboratori perché
non si creano il problema del contesto
Dove si trovano con le persone con cui
si trovano non mettono dei paletti fra
noi e loro ci trattano semplicemente
come loro amici e ed è bello così no
molto
[Musica]
bello
[Applauso]
Beh quando ero bambina io guardavo
sempre dove gli altri non
guardavano crescendo questa è diventata
un'abitudine e poi è diventata un lavoro
infatti nel 2005 ho posato il mio
sguardo sul carcere di Taranto ed è lì
che comincia la nostra strada
rivoluzionaria si trasforma prende una
forma fino ad arrivare a Lecce nel 2011
quando il progetto Io ci provo si
trasferisce qui nel carcere e diventa
una compagnia stabile di teatro che
inizia a tracciare la sua strada
percorribile visibile dall'interno
all'esterno del carcere e
viceversa Io ci provo è un atto
politico è una modalità di vita una
modalità di vita che vuole esistere e
che vuole accorciare le distanze tra la
città reclusa e la città libera vedete
l'evolversi della storia della vita
sociale ha sempre fatto di tutto per
allontanare la reclusione dalle nostre
vite e dagli occhi di ognuno di noi
escludendola così dai nostri pensieri ma
anche dal perimetro delle nostre città
noi vogliamo riportarla in primo piano
vogliamo riportarla sotto gli occhi di
tutti perché vogliamo far capire che il
carcere la reclusione non possono essere
assolutamente non possono riguardare
solo coloro che quel luogo lo abitano
tutti i giorni guardare dove nessuno
guarda dovrebbe essere una
necessità dell'essere umano dovrebbe
essere una necessità della della
comunità toccare una cosa con una cosa
che non si conosce dovrebbe innescare un
motore alla curiosità e far capire che
nella diversità c'è anche la bellezza
questo è Io ci provo io ci provo è un
laboratorio di teatro è una compagnia di
teatro e per gli attori è anche
l'occasione di sperimentare un nuovo
modello di vita che non si era mai
pensato e che quindi non esisteva prima
Grazie al percorso teatrale si possono
mettere in discussione tutti ma proprio
tutti si può attraverso la lettura la
scrittura attraverso dei linguaggi e
degli strumenti di conoscenza posare il
proprio sguardo dove non si era mai
posato e quindi anche dentro se stessi e
provare a cambiare il modo di guardare
il mondo attraverso delle lenti
differenti nello stesso tempo questo fa
sperimentare L'altro l'altro il diverso
da te ma anche l'altro come comunità
quella stessa comunità che poi ci
accoglie e accoglierà anche chi ha
scontato la sua
pena l'incontro con l'altro Parliamoci
chiaro genera sempre delle riflessioni
dei pensieri che prima non avevamo
generato da soli e quindi il prodotto
artistico che viene fuori dal nostro
lavoro è frutto di questo processo non
può essere guardato come un semplice
spettacolo perché non lo è È un processo
molto complesso vedete
e il teatro per noi è come la vita che
si sta sperimentando di nuovo non è uno
spettacolo e basta e la costruzione di
uno spettacolo è sempre una cosa molto
molto complicata perché ha vede tante
cose insieme c'è bisogno di fiducia di
ricerca dentro se stessi di ascolto di
relazione e di amore in un carc tutto
questo è ancora più complicato Ecco
perché noi lavoriamo con il teatro e non
con il carcere Noi lavoriamo con le
persone e non con i detenuti Noi
lavoriamo per l'abolizione del carcere
prima nelle nostre
menti la pazienza la forza il coraggio
l'accoglienza la severità il sorriso la
fiducia la diplomazia l'attenzione e
l'amore questo tutto questo e io ci
provo l'istituzione carcere non sostiene
il progetto economicamente ma ci offre
quel sostegno indispensabile affinché il
nostro lavoro possa compiersi la nostra
strada rivoluzionaria è stata fino ad
ora lavorare con impegno e serietà
all'interno di un luogo difficile chiuso
con delle regole un luogo dove nessuno
oltre noi riusciva a intravedere umanità
passione apertura dove nessuno ci
credeva oggi possiamo dire a distanza di
5 anni che Questa istituzione carcere
lavora insieme a noi ci prova insieme a
noi superando molto spesso dei grandi
ostacoli delle paure dei pregiudizi
perché è la prima volta anche per loro
Siamo una squadra speciale e lo dico con
grande fiducia che questa Squadra
Speciale continui ancora a lavorare e a
percorrere questa strada rivoluzionaria
così complicata Io ci provo e la storia
di persone che vogliono cambiare la loro
strada e provare a percorrere quella
strada rivoluzionaria che il teatro ha
evocato in loro siamo riusciti in questi
5 anni a portare più di 600 persone
l'anno all'interno del carcere a vedere
i nostri spettacoli più di 10000 fuori a
vedere i nostri spettacoli siamo
riusciti ad andare nei teatri del centro
della città a non essere più invisibili
siamo riusciti a portare con l'articolo
21 più di 15 detenuti alla volta a
lavorare fuori in con un lavoro
artistico e culturale pagato retribuito
come persone oneste un lavoro culturale
che genera a sua volta apertura e
comunità vi assicuro che non è una cosa
semplice e l'abbiamo fatto Grazie
all'istituzione che c'è stata accanto e
a creduto insieme a noi siamo riusciti a
cambiare la vita da almeno 30 persone
che per noi sono uguali a 100 e sapete
cosa significa questo che il nostro
obiettivo è quello giusto che si può
cambiare che questa è la strada giusta e
lo si può fare oggi non fra 100 anni ma
oggi nel nostro
presente la si può chiamare strada
rivoluzionaria ma in realtà Per noi è
una delle tante strade possibili per non
lasciare
solle il carcere la reclusione ma per
non demandare più questo problema della
sicurezza solo a quell'istituzione ma
per prendercelo un pochino tutti come
problema Parliamoci chiaro siamo tutti
parte di questo mondo siamo tutti figli
di questa terra e nessuno ci aveva mai
detto che la vita era una cosa semplice
e non lo è non lo è in una società che
risponde al male con il male che genera
antagonisti al posto di fratelli non lo
è in una società che allontana sempre di
più il fuori dal dentro Ecco noi
crediamo che in una società civile si
debba garantire a tutti ma proprio a
tutti una
possibilità una possibilità è un aiuto
un accompagnamento nel superare le
difficoltà che tutti noi abbiamo seppur
di natura diversa non una politica
dell'abbandono ma una politica
dell'accompagnamento questo io ci provo
noi ci proviamo ci proviamo ad essere
esseri umani Uniti per il cambiamento e
ci riusciamo Io ci provo una pratica che
vuole esistere a tutti i costi e
consentitemi adesso un ringraziamento
sentito speciale all'amministrazione
penitenziaria che in questo momento
insieme alla polizia penitenziaria sta
vivendo un momento difficile ma ogni
giorno quella stessa istituzione e la
polizia penitenziaria ci prova insieme a
noi
un'ultima solo chiusa perché ci tengo
non è evaso uno dei nostri detenuti
della compagnia teatrale non facciamo
che l'evasione di un detenuto possa
compromettere il percorso che sta
facendo una città insieme a
un'istituzione così chiusa e difficile
Grazie a tutti
i